[Musik]
welche zutaten stecken in lecce salami
wir zeigen euch wie schnell und günstig
die herstellung ist und wie man
frikadellen ganz ohne tierische produkte
herstellen kann
aber schmeckt das auch im
ostwestfälischen harsewinkel besuchen
wir einen waren die wurst pionier seit
40 jahren liefert die firma window
wurstwaren an alle großen handelsketten
irgendwann lockte der neue kundenkreis
der vegetarier 2014 brachte die firma
als erste in deutschland eine
vegetarische salami auf den markt
was anfangs ganz schön investitionen
schluckte sorgt heute für schnell
verdientes geld
eine normale salaam herstellung dauert
circa vier wochen mit der von der von
der produktion bis hin zur nach der
reifung eine vegetarische salami können
sie innerhalb von 24 stunden herstellen
und so funktioniert's klar milcheiweiß
erbsen mail und allerhand pülverchen
werden zu einem teig vermengt
konsistenz geschmack und farbe entstehen
schon jetzt durch zugabe verschiedener
hilfsstoffe und nicht erst später durch
lange reifung
[Musik]
das resultat ist eine masse der mann gar
nicht ansieht dass sie ohne fleisch
auskommt
nach dem abfüllen ist sie von normaler
wurst gar nicht mehr zu unterscheiden
jetzt muss die vegetarische salami nur
noch für zwölf stunden im wasserdampf
garen
dann ist sie auch schon fertig im
vergleich zum original spart das nicht
nur zeit sondern auch jede menge energie
und werden das einmal ausgerechnet wir
produzieren im jahr ungefähr 20.000
tonnen wurst waren 12.000 alami wenn wir
das komplett von vegetarischen von
vegetarischen produkten über setzen
würden wäre das für uns eine
energieeinsparung von circa eine million
euro die wurst ist also nicht nur gut
fürs gewissen sie beglückt auch die
hersteller den kunden bezahlen im laden
sogar mehr dafür als für herkömmliche
salami ganz frei von tierischen zutaten
sind salamis und andere rohwürste
allerdings nicht denn bis jetzt gelingt
es der industrie nur durch den einsatz
von hühnereiweiß und milchpulver dass
die wurst so auf der zunge zergeht wie
eine aus fleisch
[Musik]
sebastian lege weiß bei frikadellen geht
sogar ganz ohne tier und das will er
heute einem befreundeten metzger
schmackhaft machen
bis jetzt ist der trend zum
vegetarischen fleischersatz an den
meisten metzgereien vorbeigegangen
[Musik]
genau so ist es auch bei peter in hofen
in seinem geschäft frönt man noch
ungehemmt der fleischeslust sebastian
lege findet höchste zeit das sortiment
zu erweitern
[Musik]
von tina sebastian geht ja wunderbar du
bist nicht was sie hier in der kiste
habe da springt auf alle fälle alles was
sie jemals gesehen hast
jetzt zeigt mal wieder ein original ich
meine das ist ja in düsseldorf wirklich
berühmt also frikadelle hat seit
hunderten jahren ihren festen platz auf
allen speisekarten dieser welt und da
habe ich ja auch ein kleines frikadellen
setup schon aufgebaut
sie ist ohne biss ohne zaubertricks
einfach mit liebe gemacht sehr schnell
schweinefleisch und rindfleisch bilden
die basis für metzger in hofen speaker
denn beides vermengt er im kutter mit
zwiebeln brot und gewürzen bis ein
geschmeidiger teig entsteht der sich
schön formen lässt und später beim
braten nicht zerfällt ein sinnliches
erlebnis
und nun zur veganen frikadelle es ist
erst mal nur ein beutel sammelsurium
hier ist mal eine gewürzmischung da
kannst du noch nicht viel dran riechen
und hier schlummert das fleisch drittel
naja kann ich schon mal schwer gespannt
das wird schon ein bisschen gegen meinen
berufsethos gehen konnte nur noch durch
arbeit aber die zielgruppen erweiterung
die sich dadurch ergibt sich ja ich habe
mir noch eine backkartoffeln anbieten
oder backkartoffeln ist er wieder so ein
ehrliches ding die basis für sebastian
legis bulette bildet getrocknetes
weizeneiweiß
auch gluten oder seiten genannt später
soll es ein ähnliches mundgefühl
erzeugen wie echtes fleisch
[Musik]
das erz ist denn so das gesicht de facto
von ja von dem erscheinungsbild hier
irgendwann sind wir im raumschiff und
essen da so riegel und also endlich mal
wieder ein kalb haxen riegels kommen
[Musik]
gluten bindemittel gewürzmischung die
veggie frikadelle kommt ganz ohne
frische zutaten aus das muss zwar nicht
schlecht sein ist aber optisch nicht so
der bringer mit dem grillen ändert sich
das zum glück
sebastians leitern bürger machen sich
[Musik]
rein optisch kündet das ja so eine
rindfleisch variante seien bei mir oder
ich habe ihn nur metzger theke so sehen
würde heißen theke würde ich nicht
kaufen
nein auf keinen fall ich würde sagen was
sind das für komische frage aber die
probleme sind ja das auge ist zwar mit
aber was zählt ist tochter geschmack und
was sagt der geübte gaumen von
metzgermeister in hofen
[Musik]
außen chris christie außen aber bei dem
gesamten fleisch bis erlebnis ein
bisschen anders noch also ist nicht
erreicht hoch lebe das ehrbare handwerk
die heimat der frikadelle ist das
fleischerfachgeschäft na immerhin
knusprig und cross schmecken sebastians
fleischfrei bilder
[Musik]
und bei der geschmacks bewertung ist der
traditionsmesse möglicherweise auch
nicht ganz so neutral
[Musik]
deshalb soll ein anderer experte
entscheiden bulldogge kalle
er hat die alles entscheidende wahl
fleisch oder vegetarisch wofür
entscheidet sich kalle
[Musik]
vegetarisch oder fleischtheke beim
geruch scheint die vegane würzmischung
kaliß feine nase durchaus anzusprechen
aber zu guter letzt schnappt er sich das
fleisch genauso wie mutter natur ist für
hunde wie ihn vorgesehen hat
vielleicht ist der zenit der veggie
welle schon überschritten
laut statistik belassen es viele kunden
beim einmaligen griff zum fleisch ersatz
und bei einer untersuchung der stiftung
warentest waren einige vegetarische
produkte zudem mit mineralöl rückständen
belastet ein urteil gut bekamen von 24
getesteten produkten gerade mal 6
[Musik]
wie schmeckt die wurst habt ihr eine
vorliebe für eine bestimmte sorte oder
lass dir lieber die finger davon
schreibt es uns in die kommentare
und wo ist die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser